sue chantry is one of the 21 000
newly recruited contact tracers an
occupational health nurse
she's currently completing her online
training
and unlike most traces her clinical
experience
means she can handle more complex cases
we will be working from home um very
much
remotely with almost like a call system
where we will then contact individuals
and be able to give the guidance
aligning with the public health
information that we've been advised to
give
contact traces are just part of test
track and trace the political plan to
help
lift lockdown but the uk's capacity to
pull off that plan
is once again facing scrutiny it's a
very hard thing to achieve
to get a well-functioning track and
trace system in place
we need to be clear that that's working
well without that
i think there's a risk that we would
you know return to a situation where the
epidemic might increase
testing is up but not consistently
hitting the 100
000 daily target and although the
contact traces have been hired they're
yet to start
they will work alongside a new app
currently being trialled on the isle of
wight
we were always going to download it and
i haven't come across anyone personally
um in my family or my friendship circle
that hasn't wanted to
it's been more a case of on social media
seeing people that are quite anti
the app um because they're worried about
about what that information
is being used for and where it's going
to go if a user gets infected with kobit
19.
but many say the uk is falling behind
other countries singapore's app's been
running for weeks
and south korea has a highly effective
track and trace system
country after country from iceland to
singapore we hear that
digital contact tracing apps are not
necessarily the thing that makes a
difference
what does make a difference is a
comprehensive manual contact
tracing regime that's really well
resourced and and
has wide coverage although labour
intensive
test track and trace has powerful
potential
it could ease lock down and prevent a
second peak but only if capacity is
urgently increased and that say some
remains the challenge
laura bundock sky news